ofreciendo protección contra posibles
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas de
seguridad hombres armados de la etnia
karen escoltan a unos 2.000
manifestantes en su mayoría profesores y
estudiantes están escuchando los
llamados de los sindicatos a una huelga
general con el objetivo de bloquear la
economía de mianmar
fue anoche
sin embargo la junta advirtió a los
funcionarios que serían despedidos y
continuaban con el boicot el ejército ha
intensificado su represión contra los
manifestantes en los últimos días más de
50 personas han muerto desde el inicio
de las manifestaciones lo que ha
provocado una condena internacional el
lunes australia confirmó que había
suspendido su cooperación de defensa con
mianmar
esas necesidades de desarrollo
humanitario apoyo y enfoque son las que
hemos trabajado con mucho cuidado para
asegurarnos de que todavía podemos
cumplir pero no lo haremos a través de
una agencia gubernamental
también hemos tenido un embargo sobre
cualquier venta militar a mianmar y
mantendremos nuestra política de
sanciones bajo estrecha revisión de
estados unidos gran bretaña y canadá han
endurecido varias restricciones al
ejército de mianmar pero si bien pueden
ser simbólicamente importantes no está
claro si las sanciones impuestas hasta
ahora tendrán un gran impacto la mayoría
de los principales generales ya están
sancionados y algunos expertos afirman
que la diplomacia sostenida sería más
efectiva
el ejército niega su responsabilidad por
las muertes durante las protestas y ha
defendido la toma de poder alegando
fraude en las elecciones de noviembre